[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Ryan Tellez is here
good to see you my friend good to see
you too that's it's Halloween it is it's
Halloween it is Halloween you can feel
it you go to horror movies and pumpkins
and trick-or-treating and I might be a
little too old for trick-or-treating
you probably no uh but uh you know I've
been watching some horror movies we're
watching more than ever because it's the
holiday season you know a lot of bad
ones but I did see a good one and I saw
one called smile and I really enjoyed it
and guess what I got both the leads of
that movie to come next week so we will
see them next week Kyle gallner and soci
bacon
yeah they were just here yeah and I had
no idea at all because I looked her up
after and it was Kevin Bacon and uh Kyra
sedgwick's daughter isn't that didn't
know isn't that fun very pretty bright
fun eccentric talented actress she
nailed it
anyway
another awesome person that you're about
to Listen to If you those of you who
listen to the podcast and don't uh you
know Veer away when you don't know
someone or you know this guy is is a
legend to me he's a legend to many
people he's a legend his name is Tom
Holland not the actor Tom Holland you
can see Ryan is sitting right in front
of my Fright Night poster he signed it
you're so cool Brewster
Tom Holland he did Child's Play created
that wrote that he did wrote Psycho two
um
a ton of stuff the guy has done some
amazing work we became friends I played
tennis with him before I've gone on
Hikes with him I love his wife I got him
to do the podcast actually he called me
says I want to talk about my new book
which sounds incredible but you guys are
going to dig that I appreciate you
listening and making this podcast the
podcast you're listening to it means the
world to me and it really helps out
please write a review after the podcast
is over after you listen to it hopefully
it'll be good review and our socials if
you want to follow us which helps are uh
inside of you pod on Twitter inside of
you podcast on Instagram and Facebook
you can watch on YouTube you can listen
anywhere uh it'd be great go to the
inside you online store new merch great
merch a whole bunch of Smallville stuff
sign stuff tumblers coffee mugs anything
you can imagine and of course go to
sunspin.com any minute we should have uh
somewhere on that site with new sunspin
t-shirts for the band uh new Sun spin
mugs since been calendars since been CDs
that are going to be for order available
before they come out
so you might want to get on that go to
sunspin.com keep checking and you can
also book us on a zoom you can also book
us the band so there's a lot of fun
there I think that's it and of course
patreon if you don't know what patreon
is they really support the podcast in
more ways than one I give them shout
outs at the end of every episode the top
tiers they get packages more importantly
they keep the show alive and I couldn't
do the show without them I always say
that so thank you all patrons go to
patreon.com inside of you and I'll send
you a message after you sign up uh
that is pretty much it
um I can't wait for you guys to hear
this podcast I think uh Tom was a lot of
fun so Ryan did you enjoy Tom I love
good old Hollywood stories like I love
when the good better I don't know much
about him but I know when the veterans
come in you're gonna get some stories
yeah and they're good great stories and
you know I was surprised by a lot of
things but we'll let you listen to it
let's get inside of Tom Holland it's my
point
Michael Rosenberg
foreign
[Music]
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience I can't believe I can't
believe I'm sitting here with the Tom
Holland not the English actor Tom
Holland folks but Tom Holland the gifted
writer and director also actor now
novelist uh you're sitting you're the
first guest to actually sit in front of
his poster I think actually Kiefer
Sutherland sat right in front of his
Lost Boys poster but you are sitting in
front of the one of my favorite movies
of all time
it's Halloween this is out Halloween and
this is the perfect time for it but you
directed and wrote one of my favorite
movies of all time and a lot of people
feel this way a lot Fright Night
thank you thank you thank you I mean
it's just it's one of those movies that
you watch as when I was I don't know in
my teens and it's one of those movies at
last you could watch it again and again
and it still works it's not like those
movies that you watch and you're like
huh I remember Motel Hell being kind of
scary but uh I don't know it's not that
great anymore and then but this is one
that holds up and you've had a long
career you've done a lot of stuff you
look at your resume and I'm like going
holy [ __ ] psycho two you wrote child
which was a success Child's Play created
Road directed Langoliers Fright Night
thinner it's just like I mean you're a
legend you know that right you know
you're a legend you're one of those big
directors that people look up to I do I
I did not know it it started about oh I
don't know a long time ago maybe
even I don't know 16 17 years ago Rob G
Rob galluzzo if you know him who's that
he's a he's a horror fan right and he's
he's the first one that appeared on my
doorstep knocking on my door because he
was crazy in love with psycho too and he
ended up doing the uh documentary of
psycho too but that was the first
inkling that I had that the movies that
I had done decades previously still had
a life and were appreciated was this the
way this guy showed up to your house he
showed up with another friend of his
from Long Island
and he wanted to do a documentary on
psycho too and he knew everything about
it really yeah and but he but you know
then we we got into it and he couldn't
afford to get the the the photographs
from the movie from Universal because
they were so expensive to license right
and I had all the Polaroids that I'd
taken on set me and Tony me and Robert
Loggia me and Vera Miles and I let him
use them in this in the in the in the
documentary for free wait you so you are
like it sounds to me and I think I've
been to your house a few times we've
been on Hikes I've seen your stuff I
Love Your Wife by the way how's she
doing is she doing a little better yeah
yeah she is doing better
yeah yeah yeah it's it's all right yeah
it's all right it's all right that's all
right I love her she's got an attitude
on her yeah
I like her
um but
is this something that you always wanted
to do where like were you fascinated by
horror I mean I know you acted a little
bit when you were younger and you
actually acted not too many years ago
but is it did you always wanna
did you like the Macabre the dark the
was that always in your mind and what
started all that well it's very very
hard to describe Michael because it was
such a different time when I
I was a horror fan before there were
horror fans I'm talking the late 50s I'm
taught this this is Stephen King's
growing up it's pretty much the same
thing it was EC Comics if you look at
his short stories he's doing EC Comics
you see Comics is like 1955 or 56 then
they created such a uh a furor that they
were banned and what happened that of
course made high school kids like me go
absolutely crazy for EC Comics
and when they were banned a small group
maybe four or five other guys it was
guys not girls in Austin Public High
School started trading EC Comics under
the table and DC Comics was a horror
kind of thing you see Commerce as like
tales of the crypt oh or like fengorian
yeah well they way before way before
vanguardia
this is back in the late 50s so it was
horror was a hidden pleasure or uh yeah
or a dangerous pleasure and the only
horror movies that were around really
are what I grew up with was hammer and
AIP and AIP American International was
ripping off Hammer right but so I grew
up with Christopher Lee Peter Cushing
you know uh uh yeah yeah I mean you know
the uh I had lunch with Christopher Lee
once believe it or not really just after
he had finished Lord of the Rings I
ended up at uh at uh uh guy Green's
house invited guy green won the Academy
Award in 19. 47 or 48 for Great
Expectations he shot it wow and there
was a very active British community in
in Hollywood there has been since
forever David given Etc and they had a
big party for David lean and Christopher
Lee was there and Christopher Lee was
there and it was David Lee because he
was doing the he was he was doing a the
new print of uh of Lawrence of Arabia I
think and so everybody was anybody in
the British Community was there and I
ended up at that table with my wife and
Christopher Lee were you Starstruck uh
yes but not a star truck as I was when I
ended up with
Vincent Price oh you ended up with
Vincent Price I ended up having dinner
with Vincent Price and his wife was her
name Carl Brown and at Roddy McDowell's
house come on and Roddy did it because I
had originally written Fright Night for
Vincent Price I thought he would play
you know it was Peter right right right
and well that's why I'm Peter Vincent
the uh his surprise and Peter Cushing
and uh I I sat there and wanted to talk
about all the great horror movies that
that Vincent Price had had made and all
he wanted to talk about was Art and the
cookbook he just finished
so I couldn't get anything out of them
really but just listening to that voice
yes yes yes yes ghouls from every two
months
and even though you try to you know who
that is right yeah you know that's
Impressions
yes he was also in The Brady Bunch but
he did a lot of movies he was in The
Brady Bunch he was in an episode of The
Brady Bunch years ago that I didn't know
yeah I think they went to Hawaii and uh
Vincent Price was was there and he was
kind of this eccentric character but
yeah he was but he also did Wax Museum
and no he could really act oh man he was
great he was just he had such a presence
yes but he could do character work too
if you go back and look at the movies in
the 40s and the 50s you could see them
really working Noir he did noir films
right were your parents a little freaked
out by the fact that you loved horror
did you let it be known at a young age
were they like going up Tom's a little
different yeah no exactly they they they
wrote a letter to the first job I got
was as a Apprentice a Bucks County
Playhouse in Bucks County Pennsylvania
and the man who ran it was named Ellis
Michael Ellis and my parents wrote him a
letter which they kept and they were
saying we think something's a little
wrong with our son he may be a little
bit different how is he doing as an
apprentice of Bucks County Playhouse
well that was anyway that was what did
he say did he write back no I didn't I
don't know why you don't know what he
said all I saw was their letter you know
but you were always in horror movies
like into seeing horror movies and
reading these magazines and whatever
that was in your world at a young age
yes but there were there
there wasn't a fan Community out there
you were just really weird and one of a
tiny minority and the other one was
science fiction films in the late 50s
you had you had the the horror films
which were the the hammer films were
highly saturated the color right and the
the the the the cutting and the the way
they shot them were very standard
because they had great sets they'd
gotten all these old old houses in
London they shot in them they always had
a wide shot to show you how great the
set was first right and maybe you got
the over the shoulders you very seldom
got a single and I don't know if I ever
saw an insert you know no inserts back
then yeah no inserts back then yeah well
so I mean film film didn't start to
change till breathless God godar who did
jump Cuts I've never seen a jump cut
before in my life the MTV style started
back then with him and that would be
that would be 60s
no late 50s 1960s look up breathless and
see when this Ryan looks Jean-Paul
Belmondo you know what's crazy is like
you went to law school
that's crazy but but you aren't thinking
of becoming a director or a writer
really at this point when when you're
studying law right
I wasn't seriously studying law I was an
actor I started working very very young
I was under contract to Warner Brothers
when I was 19 and I have been a member
of sag since oh my gosh
1961. how how did you get a contract
with Warner Brothers at 19
I there was I wanted to get into film
and when I had apprenticed at the bus
county playhouse
all they could tell me was various
acting classes in New York
so what I started to do
was I signed up for the HB Studio on 21
Banks I went to HBO in New York in the
90s mid 90s
yeah okay for a year I went there HP
studios Okay so I did I did that in like
my I guess between my before I went to
my first year of college and I got the
Northwestern uh no yeah Northwestern but
I was in New York in that summer before
and that's when I started to get
commercials and then after my first
freshman year at Northwestern which
didn't have a film school when I became
an actor because there was no way to get
in the film there was no way to get to
Hollywood or to learn how to make films
and I just I don't know I was just
desperate to get into film and because
there was no way in except acting I
became an actor
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
better help I don't know what we do with
that better help uh you know I have been
lately dealing with a lot of anxiety and
what happens is I hyper focus on all
these negative things Ryan that keep
spiraling and I can't I can't it's hard
to focus it's and it exhausts me and
gives me anxiety
and these thoughts kind of just and I
know it's not I shouldn't be thinking
all these things and it's in my mind I
can't put it to rest a lot of times
and um
you know it could be tough to to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode and you know especially when you're
facing challenges in life and I know
that therapy helps that talking to
someone and having them talk to you
objectively about what works train
professionals helps it just does I doing
it on my own isn't working it's just not
working
if I don't have someone to talk to I
will just continue to spiral there's no
way out that's how I feel
do you feel that way yeah
um you have to talk to somebody you know
people always say well how did you get
into therapy it's because I just
couldn't solve these problems on my own
I couldn't you know it's you could say
you're going to do these things and
you're saying oh you what happens is you
just bottle stuff up folks we just
bottle things up until it becomes very
toxic and our body feels it
physiologically we feel the effects of
you know pain depression anxiety and it
takes a toll on your mind and your body
and that is why I got into therapy and
I'll tell you A lot of times I have
nothing to talk about and for the first
five minutes like why am I here what am
I doing and by the end of it I'm like
thank God I'm talking to somebody my
Lord look if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option Ryan here does better help it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists any time
um you know a lot of times people are
selling things and there's ads you have
to read to me this is the easiest read
ever because it's just something I could
talk about forever and
um look better help is is a great place
it's a it's a place to to help a lot of
people when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com inside today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside of you
is brought to you by Freedom grooming
where were you Freedom grooming when I
was shaving my head every day on
Smallville
I love you guys these guys are terrific
uh they have the new flex series
electric razor and it's magnificent
trust me on this one at Freedom grooming
we make the flex series electric shaver
which uniquely is designed to flex and
Contour to the curve of your head for a
smoother faster and safer shave without
the risks of Nicks Cuts irritations or
ingrowns shave 50 percent more hair in a
single stroke compared to traditional
razors expect shave times of two to
three minutes not 10 to 15. never cut
yourself shaving again the flex series
Safeguard technology means no Nicks no
ingrown hairs no problems and the flex
series waterproof design means you can
shave in the shower with or without
shaving cream shave wet or shave dry
since even the sharpest blades dull with
use Freedom created the close shave plan
with a close shave plan you'll never run
out of fresh sharp blades delivered to
your door every six weeks with free
shipping all act active close shave plan
members are upgraded to a lifetime
warranty and it's completely
customizable adjust skip or cancel your
plan anytime and we have over ten
thousand five star reviews you know I
have a buddy Ryan
my friend Joe he shaves his head
he's never felt anything like this he's
used to I won't say that the name the
brand but he always cuts himself he's
always got little cuts and little
bruises Nicks and what have you and this
really works for him I think people are
always looking for something that really
makes their life easier and there's
nothing worse than going to a a
restaurant with blood trickling down
your head so stop Deli slicing your
scalp with traditional razors try
Freedom today or get it as a gift with
your exclusive 20 off by going to
freedomgrooming.com
inside that's
freedomgrooming.com slash inside inside
inside of you is brought to you by
Shopify we've talked about Shopify a lot
Ryan
um I use Shopify I've used it since the
Inception of this podcast I use it for
the other podcast talk Ville everybody I
know has a podcast or you know is in
some kind of business uses Shopify
doesn't have to be just for podcasts but
for your business uh small business big
business whatever you want what I love
is it's so easy to navigate I mean it's
so simple
and you could take you could keep track
of what's selling the best what's
selling the least how many products you
have left it's all right there for you
contact your customers give discounts
it's
tremendously easy and I love Shopify
Shopify makes it simple to sell to
anyone from anywhere whether your thing
is vintage tees or recipes for ghee
start selling with Shopify and join the
platform simplifying Commerce for
millions of your favorite businesses
worldwide with Shopify you'll create an
online store in your Vibe at discover
new customers and grow the following
that keeps them coming back Shopify has
all the sales channels sorted so your
business keeps growing from an in-person
POS system to an all-in-one Commerce
platform even across social media
platforms like Tick Tock Facebook and
Instagram and thanks to 24 7 support and
free libraries
and thanks to 24 7 support and free
libraries full of educational content
shopify's got you every step of the way
it's how every minute new sellers around
the world make their first sale with
Shopify and you will too when you're
ready to launch your thing into the
spotlight do it with Shopify the
Commerce platform backing millions of
businesses down the street and around
the globe go on try Shopify for free and
start selling anywhere this is
possibility powered by Shopify sign up
for a free trial at shopify.com inside
all lowercase go to shopify.com inside
to start selling online today
shopify.com inside
and by the way
you're a good looking man you've always
been a good looking man do you think
some of your looks could help you out a
little bit too about about 99.9 percent
because I I came into New York after my
after my first year of college at
Northwestern and I got a seven year
contract at Warner Brothers they flew me
out here and Jack Warner himself signed
me what was it like I mean when your
contract ended with Warner Brothers what
were you thinking like what do I do now
or how do I am I going to still get work
am I gonna all that what but what made
your focus turn to
directing or writing writing was really
at first that what started right I got
in the ACT well I'd start I wanted to
write from like I went from when I was
13. I have been trying to write short
stories and then later novels and I
couldn't do it
anyway the the uh I got into the active
Studio down here on the long pray and he
studied with Strasbourg oh God I
couldn't get rid of him yeah really oh
God yeah wherever I ended up you seemed
to end up there you do a 20 minute you
do you do a scene for 20 minutes then he
talked for it for 90. you know I mean
and my eyes crossed I never this this
what year was this it'd be like
I met Stewart Stern there in 1906 with
67 through 70 or 71 I was in the actor's
studio and they had what they and I was
working production in commercials both
in front of the camera and behind the
camera and I was making enough to keep
going along with the acting jobs it was
pretty tight depending on what month it
was some months I had
comparatively a lot of money and some
months I was dead broke
and I got in the actor studio and they
had something called the playwright
swing and they had writers screenwriters
and they wrote one act plays and they
cast them out of the studio and I got
cast the number of those one-act plays
and I met a number of aspiring
screenwrites working screenwriters Jim
Bridges and I became friends uh I can't
remember Carol Eastman her brother uh
so that's how you started getting really
creative in writing started writing well
I what was happening was I was doing
these I was doing these plays and the
directors would say Okay cross here or
do this or that or pick up here and I
was saying to myself no uh-uh you don't
want to do that it's better if you do
this
and I became more and more aware
that I had an instinct for directing for
staging for making the scenes work I can
take a scene and put it on his feet and
I can get something out of it right you
know somehow and you knew that inside
yourself that hey I'm I'm good I know
what I'm doing I started to discover it
and then I had people like like Jim Jim
did the paper chase uh
uh yeah well he leveraged himself into
directing John Houseman well John
Houseman was something else too yeah I
met John Houseman yes through Stuart
Stern I'm sorry Mr Holland but he almost
was like a Hitchcock and I kept asking
you about uh about Orson Welles
oh
oh the things I've done okay the uh you
know so anyway so I realized that that I
would like to direct I couldn't get in
through doing commercials no I could if
I started to direct uh uh
um the really inexpensive uh children's
toys commercials on the weekends the uh
tomka and [ __ ] no bigger than that but
Fisher Price
but you were directing commercials for
kids that were airing on TV yes yeah and
were you making good money doing that no
but I was making a living
the uh
and everybody around me who was getting
it the people around me were getting a
chance to direct
drama we're doing it through being a
successful screenwriters and leveraging
themselves into an opportunity to direct
most of which they could not do right
but some of them like Jim Bridges could
and uh that gave me hope and I had
being a nice middle class boy which
basically I am a lower middle class with
aspirations to get solidly into the
upper middle class uh
I I started to write screenplays and I
went to the I had been covering myself
I've I was compelled to get a college
degree my life has been sent spent in
scene study classes there's hardly
anybody that I that I I miss Sandy
Meisner but otherwise I study with
everybody the best that I ever had I
thought was uh
it'll come to me in a second
she was married to the to the the group
theater still Adler still Adler Stiller
Adler was hands down the best teacher
that I ever had and I know it's it's
it's it's it's it's to say it's almost
uh apostasy to say this but Lee
Strasburg bored me to tears bored you to
share oh my God he just talked all the
time oh God you know and it was it was
all it was all it was all one way it was
it was all about somehow you becoming
that character right it was it was all
it was all inside you know the uh it was
it was emotionally exhausting anyway I
was lost I graduated my undergraduate at
UCLA and I looked around and I had just
gotten dropped from from a pilot for a
TV series which I thought I thought was
going to change my life in Hollywood
and I was I felt you know really
rejected and really depressed and it was
hopeless and what was I doing I didn't
have a degree I wasn't trained for
anything else I you know I I'd have some
weeks where I'd make a living and I'd
have some weeks where I was starving
starving yeah the uh so I thought I
should get a college degree that's what
your mother says to you well fine but
have something to fall back right right
and so I graduated and looked around and
I didn't know what I wanted to do I had
no idea of being able to do anything
except something to do with film
so I went to UCLA Law School
and I finished the first year which is
supposedly the most difficult and I was
bored to tears yeah I mean I had made a
terrible mistake a lot of things I might
be able to do I could do windows in a
dress shop you know I could I could I
could help design a restaurant I don't
know I mean you know I could make I
could I could frame a picture I could do
a lot of things but but you know going
through uh being an attorney and reading
contracts and uh
all of that that was too much for me but
I started to use I could not stop myself
from being in love with film I was I was
at greystoke the Doheny mansion in the
third year that AFI was in existence and
I was there as the legal liaison from
UCLA
and all I did was go to the seminars go
to the Talks by the various directors
that came in I was I was like I was a
student at AFI it wasn't like I was in
the law and I I had people encouraging
me to write screenplays right and I I
started doing it and you know something
I got better
inside of you is brought to you by First
Alert did you know that a fire
department responds to a fire every 23
seconds October is fire prevention month
and we have teamed up with First Alert
the most trusted brand in fire safety to
help protect your whole home with safety
you can trust smoking carbon monoxide
alarms help provide an early warning in
the event of Home emergency having
enough First Alert smoke and carbon
monoxide alarms is one of the best
things you can do for your home and for
your family install alarms on every
level and in every bedroom of your home
now once alarms are installed it's
important to maintain them by testing
them regularly also
remember alarms don't last forever and
need to be replaced at least every 10
years they are on duty 24 7. if you
cannot remember the last time you
replaced your alarm it is best to
replace the unit completely along with
alarms fire extinguishers are essential
make sure to place fire extinguishers on
every level and in common spaces like
the kitchen and know how to use them for
more information on Fire Safety Products
safety tips and educational activities
you can do at home with your family
visit
firstalert.com
fire prevention month
first alert.com slash fire prevention
month inside you is brought to you by
Geico Geico asks how would you love a
chance to save some money on insurance
well of course you would after all who
doesn't love a great deal right and when
it comes to Great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life Geico can
help like with insurance for your car
truck motorcycle boat and RV even help
with homeowners condo or renters
coverage you could save even more with a
special discount when you bundle your
coverages plus add the easy to use Geico
mobile app available 24-hour roadside
assistance and more and choosing to
switch to Geico becomes an Easy Choice
switch today and see all the ways you
could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
and I kept writing I got a I got a
literary agent who was sending the
material out I took the bar
and I was waiting for the results of the
bar
and I sold my first screenplay
and I was like ah
and I thought to myself
well
then I got then I got the results of the
bar and I passed the bar oh wow so I was
faced with the decision I had sold one
screenplay and I have the the copy of
the check on the wall framed how much
fifteen hundred dollars was more than
I'd ever seen in one place for years
1500 bucks in nineteen
nineteen what would it be maybe
1970 three or four 1974 so that's the
most money you had ever seen
pretty much so I had a choice to make in
1974.
about whether or not I was going to be a
lawyer going to be a screenwriter and I
was so used to being poor and starving
to death and I knew that if I practiced
law I'd start to make a living and one
of the dangerous things about making a
living is you start to live up to the up
to the level of whatever money you're
making at least I had that problem right
the uh so you know so I thought well
I really would much rather get back
under film it's been my love all my life
and so I didn't practice law I kept on
writing screenplays and I was working
production once again in TV commercials
which is where you it's one of the ways
you get into making movies or television
is through becoming a a director of TV
commercials even then yeah and I I
worked for five years
until
initial well the first one was
initiation of Sarah in 1977 it was a big
TV movie right it was quite a scandal
was the first time that they that they
tossed a girl in a fountain and she came
out wearing a t-shirt and you saw her
wet hard nipples jeez oh my gosh it was
on it was on the cover of the LA Sunday
LA times that the initiation of Sarah
yeah and then I got my first movie done
uh the Beast Within yes and I wrote that
in 79 it was released in 1980 and it was
a success it made money but nobody knew
because it got buried in the wreckage of
the bankruptcy of United Artists
and I spent a year out of work
an entire year I didn't get a job and
then I was offered a a property that
nobody else in town wanted to touch
because they were sure it was it was
suicide psycho too psycho too and how
did it so Universal
asked you to write it did you have a
pitch prepared for it no they just asked
you to write it I it was Richard
Franklin the director of the Australian
director who had the assignment and he
read a couple of screenplays of mine
and he really liked one called The
Crystal Tower and uh he had me in and we
talked about psycho too and I can't tell
you how or why but he chose me to to
write it now every nobody in town wanted
to do oh yeah how do you touch it's a
masterpiece probably one of the best
horror movies in the history of uh
Cinema it is it's it's it's the
beginning oh yeah of the beginning of
horror really yeah it's it's it's the
it's the first it's the first slasher
that we did you know it was so much more
than that but the uh
and but nobody everybody knew they were
going to get ripped by the critics for
having the temerity you can't win it's a
winless situation and on top of that it
was a cable movie oh Communications
looking the credits you'll see it
and this was just as cable is coming in
and just as VHS is coming in
and uh
nobody wanted to do it but I I Richard
and I talked to you that I said the only
way you're going to get this made is a
feature film is if you get Tony Perkins
back to play Norman Bates
and Tony didn't want any part of it I
read that he didn't want any part of it
until he read your script well then so
what I had to do was try to figure out
how to make a piece of actors bait that
was so strong that one of the great
movie star actor would say I can't turn
it down and Tony blamed
psycho for ruining his career
because he had been a romantic lead
right before that
Shenandoah Valley they're all uh he'd
been a star on Broadway and look
Homeward Angel and then all of a sudden
he did psycho and everybody sees him as
that and that that really put her took
the took the edge off of uh being a
movie star right he turned him more into
a character actor
so he had very
mixed feelings about it but what I wrote
was one of the great I thought one of
the great acting parts to come out in
the horror genre because Norman starts
out coming out of the mental institution
and he's sane and he's desperately
trying to hold on to his sanity and of
course the the the the the the the
reliefs of his victims come back to
drive him mad
and at the end of the film
he kills his own mother and he's totally
raving mad so that is a hell of a
character Arc right it was it was a real
and it was a success it was the number
two movie Behind Return of the Jedi that
year that's right and that really put
you on the map didn't it that made me
that made you that like this guy did The
Impossible yes because without psycho 2
being a success they probably wouldn't
have made any more you wouldn't have had
the whole psycho Legacy a cycle you
would have had none of it you I think
there were three or four sequels to
Psycho two and then they did at least
two or three TV series right and that
last one was very good the base Motel
Bates Motel was incredible yeah I mean
so you know but that more importantly
got you the opportunity probably to
direct I mean pretty soon after it it
gave me the visibility that if I wrote a
few more scripts and they did well that
I was going to have a shot and then I
wrote Cloak and Dagger uh uh which was a
success yeah it was a success the uh
I've happened to love that script the uh
you're a class of 1984 which became a
cult that became a cold hit but at the
time that was we're once again you're
you're in
you're in the harsh genre in the bottom
of the basement you don't at that time
and we're back what year am I in I'm in
ninth we're in uh psycho two is 1982.
right so 1982 to 84 or 85 when I did
fright night I did I had a failure with
uh screen for help which is Michael
Winner I have stories about all these
people
the I had uh I had Cloak and Dagger
Richard Franklin directed that uh
and I I had uh Class of 84 Mark Lester
did Michael J fox was in that right
first movie first movie Michael J fox
did did you meet him no I did not I was
not on location that was this that was a
Canadian tax shelter ah of course the
but I mean I I think it's the best movie
that Mark Lester ever did the I mean
that thing works and the actors were all
just terrific and I think a few of them
are directors now but during cloak and
daggers when you came up with the idea
for fright night right what happened was
they came to me and they said uh we want
to do we want to do we want to do a
remake of the window the window was the
juvenile version by Cornell Woolrich of
rear window and Cornell Woolrich wrote
both books right and it is the
quintessential boy who cried Wolf's
story and I said you can't do this this
is this is just I've seen this too many
times it's too thin you know and that's
when I came up with the imaginary
character Jack fly I wrote an original
basically Cloak and Dagger is an
original
and uh but I said if you really want to
do a kid looking out the window
and seeing a murder in the house next
door and you want to make it fresh and
you want to make it appealing to your
younger demographic
have a kid love a harm yet of a Mad
horror fan look out his window and see a
vampire chomping down in the house next
door and everybody thought I was nuts I
mean they all thought I was crazy really
it's such a cool idea I went and took a
meeting at Universal Tom Mount I think
and I couldn't convince him everybody
thought I was crazy now you got to
remember that moment in time
vampires were excuse the expression dead
dead dead
the the vampire the the vamp the most
recent vampire movie was love at first
bite with George Hamilton right which is
farce right when they start doing Forest
it lets you know that the genre is dead
it's exhausted it has to be reinvented
right it needs a breather uh uh you've
you see that with yeah sure you don't
see it all the time see it all the time
and so
I
I you didn't give up no I couldn't get
the idea out of my head because it was
so delicious yeah and and really so I
sat down I couldn't think how to I just
kept saying well what would what would
Charlie Brewster do if he if he had a
vampire next door well who would he go
to for help nobody's ever gonna believe
him and then I thought of all those
horror hosts that I had grown up with oh
yeah you know Vampira
Vincent Price well well they had I grew
up with what they call the Friday Night
Frights if you wanted to find a horror
movie on TV back in the like in the 60s
you had to go to Friday night 11 o'clock
on a local station
which would have the temerity you know
the guts to run one and then you always
had some horrible tacky horror host
right and I mean really they did the
sets with no money Flats falling down
people who were looking but that's the
only way people would know to watch this
horror movie yeah but that but that's
what the idea spawned well that's like I
said well that's the difference if I was
Charlie Brewster I'd go to Peter Vincent
and when I had that I couldn't get home
fast enough to write I mean and I I
don't think I've ever had an exciting
experience like it because I was
literally falling on the floor and
screaming with laughter really and
pounding my feet and my hands are saying
this is so funny I can't believe this
I'm almost Champions Justin
it was it was so
so ripe with pie it was so amusing right
for possibilities so much fun I don't
know what and what it turned out to be
is a love letter to horror fans
everywhere yeah and it is and I think
what's given the what's given Fright
Night the legs that it has is that
is that horror fans recognize themselves
in it and okay AIP and and and and and
and the Peter Cushing and Christopher
they all may be gone now but every
generation has new horror figures
whether you know whether it's you know
whether it's Chucky or whether it's uh
you know uh the guy you know with a
handy for any area Michael Myers or
whoever right but
was that the most fun you've ever had
writing a script was Fright Night yes to
this day hands down yes it's one of
those things that you were like oh my
God this is brilliant this is brilliant
I'm gonna sell this I
I don't know if I thought that but I was
laughing when I wrote I mean every every
joke I told I thought of something even
funnier you know are you high yeah oh no
I wasn't I would don't in those days I
was as straight as you know as a pin the
well I mean you couldn't you know those
were the times right I mean you're
talking you know the the 80s well you're
talking though the latest started in the
late 70s you're talking about Hollywood
and uh and blow oh yeah did you ever do
blow we're on public Airway for God this
is this is a real story this is like
your life it doesn't mean you do it now
I've tried blow before uh you know I
don't do it now
yes I I tried the uh what happened was
everybody around me was doing was doing
it and it started
it started in the very early 70s and by
1980 it was a snowstorm and it was it
was it was it was wrecking it was
wrecking multi-million dollar pictures
really it wrecked people were doing it
on set all the crew it wrecked it
wrecked uh the Scorsese film New York
New York it wrecked that film that Chevy
Chase did about about the making of The
Wizard of Oz with all the little little
people in it they were so wrecked on
Blow they couldn't remember they
couldn't they couldn't hit their marks
you know so that if you go into a
meeting at a studio and the executive
you were meeting with would would put
out a glass of vase on the coffee table
and you sit there and discuss story in
between doing lines seriously yeah
seriously it was just that it was just
part of the industry and everybody said
well it's not addicting it's you know I
went I went I was working with Stuart
Stern I was riding with him when when
they were shooting Sybil and Stewart
wrote civil right and
we'd be on one side of the of the set
and on the other on the other side of
the flat Joanne Woodward and Sally
Fields would be rehearsing and I would
be sitting with the camera crew and all
of us were doing lines
I mean it was that pervasive but but
nobody had yet figured out that it was
that it ruined lives right nobody had
just caused heart attacks no nobody yet
today it's laced with fentanyl which has
killed people instantly well in those
days it would just ruin your septum you
need a nose operation right A lot of
people probably had those well I I when
I did the when I did uh when I acted
when I played the lead in the young
lawyers
I where I did a scene with uh Richard
Pryor Richard Pryor right Richard Pryor
and I had a scene and I mean oh no well
I went and I went into it he had a he
had a trailer and he was hanging out
with us and you snorted with him no what
I I don't remember me doing it because I
was working but they all were I mean
literally you couldn't move you couldn't
turn around for for the late 70s through
maybe the mid late 80s it's just part of
the norm you're unaffected by it well
what happened was I started to make
money so I could buy by the app by the
ounce I think and then what what you say
to yourself is well I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna sell all this and that will
pay for me to have a couple of extra
grams of my own without me putting out
money of course what happens is you end
up doing the entire ounce right and then
I turned around and I wasn't writing
anymore
and the last line of cocaine I ever did
was the summer of 1981 and I have not
touched it since 1981. wow because I
think it's a destroyer yeah I watched
people wreck their lives their careers
on it
who did you finally sell Fright Night to
eventually sold it to Columbia to guy
McElwain he believed in it you pitched
him or did he read the script he read
the script well he read the script after
he'd given the green light that's funny
too I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm in
pre-production on it and he calls me
desperately and says you have to change
the ending and I said what are you
talking I said well I read the script
and at the ending you have Peter Vincent
turning into a vampire they're going to
hate you if you do that you can't you
gotta you gotta end the script that's a
good no that's a good note and I and
that's when I realized he was finally
reading the script when I was in
pre-production wow
he was he was a wonderful man by the way
and I had met him
previously
I'm doing Hollywood gossip which only
the Insiders would and the historians
would possibly I had become friends with
with a young with a young woman named
Lynn geiler g-u-y-l-r
uh and her best friend was Morgan Mason
Morgan Mason was Pamela Mason's daughter
she was also James Mason's daughter okay
now nobody remembers probably who Pamela
Mason was she was the first iteration of
you
she had a talk show on radio and it was
a huge sensation wow and she was
extremely sophisticated and she had a uh
of a salon every Sunday at her house and
her house was the one that had been
built by the great silent comedian with
the with the face that never showed
anything oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah the the general the car the the the
the the house falling down on him the
train picking up things off The Trestle
by riding the train
oh I wish they had my names anyway she
had his old house and there were
phenomenal parties there was a who's who
was who's who of the previous generation
oh my goodness I mean that the one
experience I had with it prior I was in
a movie I acted in a movie called The
Walk in the spring rain with Ingrid
Bergman and Tony Quinn okay and I
couldn't believe it and I was pinching
myself all the time saying oh my gosh
that's that's Elsa from from Casablanca
I just I was like you know I was a fan
of course I mean I mean that's what I
basically have always been that's that's
what I am I mean you can look around you
can see all the things I I'm a fan I'm a
fan of horror I'm a fan of Cinema well
you're you're coming from Southern
Indiana up against the Ohio River yeah
and who even knows where that is yeah
the odds were definitely against me well
I'm probably a Poughkeepsie boy on there
there against you well yeah I'm from a
small town across the river called
Highland New York you know I yeah you
know nobody
had anything to do with any of this and
everybody thought I was crazy could you
believe the success when Fright Night
hit were you stunned I've never been
able to believe my success ever
really yeah I can't I I don't know why
I've never been able to I mean right now
I couldn't
I couldn't you had to sit there in a
test audience watching Psycho too to
realize that you'd really done something
when you heard those screams when you
heard people feeling terrible for Norman
right you know uh and then then with
fright night when you hear the laughter
roll over you you hear the screams
the biggest one I guess was was Chuck
was Child's Play I mean how did he come
up with a Chucky
I mean did this just come to you or you
were you high one night and you're like
I got this there's this doll no I I
have been a I've been extremely
disciplined as far as narcotics or
alcohol is concerned
and if anybody is out there listening
who aspires to do what Michael or I have
done
stay straight okay seriously okay well
you you take you take a hit of this
hydroponic today and it's instant
stupidity you know I mean it is forget
writing anything you're lucky if you can
sign your own name yeah the uh okay so
that's that so no I I don't know I mean
I I
can't believe I'm here
at this point I feel the same way about
you know micro I'm like how did I do it
I don't know how I I wasn't supposed to
amount to anything I I every time I do
something I'm like really they're
they're hiring me really they're it's
always the disbelief of like you know I
think our perceptions of ourselves like
how did this happen it was always a
dream
but dreams do come true you know they do
come true and sometimes you have to just
say
let's just go with it after a while you
start to say fright night's a success
psycho two is a success child's plays a
success hey my brain is working well I
can't believe we come here to discard to
this point look I I oh you don't want to
talk about all this stuff but I mean I
just have my first novel published
Fright Night Origins right it's the
first of a series and it's it's uh I
can't believe it's only been a week
today is Wednesday so it's been a week
and one day we released it did the press
release last Tuesday we could go like
yesterday
and I thought well I felt pretty good
that at least we got a sampling because
of the of the Fright Night fan base
and nobody reacted
nobody picked it up no other horror
sites mentioned no social media nothing
so I went to bed Tuesday night and
terribly disappointed I'm past the point
where I'm going to put a gun to my head
but I mean you know but I mean but I
mean I thought well I've really
miscalculated and this is after every
spent months writing writing the book
and I wrote it with a good friend called
uh Jack uh Yorick and but there was
nothing and then I woke up Wednesday
morning and it started
on Wednesday morning Bloody Disgusting
and Joe Blow picked it up
and they got it out which it's not that
it gets it it there's probably nothing
compared to the people that are
listening to us here
but for the for the community for the
horror Community the you know a couple
of those sites really get the word out
and they got it out and then all of a
sudden we started to get uh I uh uh uh
uh territon dot shop everybody I'm being
Shameless go buy the book go buy the
hardcover Fright Night Origins if you're
a horror fan if you're a fan of Fright
Night you got to get this book and where
can they get this you can get it you can
get it at uh territime.shop or you can
get it on Amazon Amazon right Amazon if
you're into one click if you're if you
want it signed you gotta buy it through
uh through through Terror time.shop let
me ask you something when they make a
sequel to Fright Night which they did
and then they rebooted it with Colin
Farrell
since you created that and wrote that do
you still get a nice check and do you
get residuals for that or do they give
you a buyout how does that work
um
oh you're upset well I mean listen I
mean I am I am to all of you aspiring
screenwriters out there aspiring
directors and actors
they screw you financially Hollywood
rapes you how do they do that because
they have definitions of this this
everyone we could be talking an hour
each on on everything of course but in
in you know how because they have the
definition the profit definition is
always is hardly ever gross which is the
only way you ever see anything it's net
points which means that they take all
the expenses off before they give before
they get to your profit participation
and they have it set up so the expenses
are such that the movie will not ever go
into profits even after 35 years thank
you very very much
mgmua now Amazon for Child's Play which
is still how many millions of dollars is
that still on the whole how many sequels
did that's did that you created it yeah
well no there were the the the the Dan
Mancini wrote the wrote the first draft
you wrote a reversion no screenplay
right and couldn't get it done in town
and I couldn't figure out how to solve
it left it came back to it when I
figured so I saw the the clown in
Poltergeist reach out from under the bed
oh the scariest thing ever that's right
scariest thing ever and what that is is
everybody is every kid has looked around
as he was falling asleep in his play
things stacked up on the shelves and on
the windowsill and have said to himself
what if my toys come alive
and I knew that that was a a premise
that would appeal worldwide and I came
back to Child's Play when I thought of
when I thought of the Hillside Strangler
the Brad duraf part right and you know
before the before that it was it was
more of a it was the the the the the
little boy it was called blood buddy the
the boy made a blood buddy of the doll
and when he fell asleep the dog got up
and killed people like his teacher at
his dentist but you felt no sympathy for
anybody there was no bad guy right and
when I put the serial murderer inside of
Chucky that's when that that's when that
damn square that was your idea oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah wow oh yeah and I I
could go on and on but so to this day
when you know they have a they have a TV
show Child's Play you don't get anything
from that no I do not nothing zero no
any back end from the child's play socks
that you have on
the merch no I did not have merch my
lawyer did the worst deal and and any
lawyer has ever done I will never
forgive him it's it's really if I only
knew now what I knew then I never would
have made the deal George Lucas he was
smart enough or he thought ahead of time
I want Mercy like nobody buys Star
reactions they gave it to her take it
they gave it to him because nobody
bought merch exactly exactly right and
he somehow kept the kept the rights
right see this is a long yeah of course
I just want to but it's just it's it's
painful to hear it not only obviously
your pain but to hear someone who was
responsible you and a couple people for
the creation of this this franchise and
not receiving a dime of it after is just
it's bewildering well the money was
always there in the merchandise that's
why David kirschner was the producer did
it because he was a he was a maven he
was a merchandise Maven right and look
at look at I can't imagine how many tens
if not hundreds of millions he's made
off the merchandise right but that's
what he did it for yeah the uh so these
are only I was just naive yeah probably
still naive but I don't think he did
okay then you're not I think you did
pretty damn well for a guy who was born
in Vassar Hospital in Poughkeepsie I've
done incredibly well right I mean you
know and you're completely
I mean you're just you're a normal guy
you're just a laid-back good humble man
of the years I've known you it's just
like wow this guy's just I can hang out
with this guy
and that's how I've always you just seem
like an older brother or whatever that I
could just hang with and who has a lot
of experience very knowledgeable very
talented but and you're still going
you're you know that's the amazing
that's the amazing part it's like you
know I look at my mom she's 75 and she's
like you know she she's already fallen
she's like because she doesn't have I'm
sorry yeah there's just a lot of stuff
going on with her health and I'm like
you look great knock on wood let's knock
on wood no I I I I spent five years
dying and I came out of it how was that
pulmonary problems uh another long but
you had heart problems no I had
sinusites I had Sinus I had consecutive
sinus infections
and they discovered that I had my
sinuses had polyps and I had to do a
sinus operation
but I almost died from that well before
that my my oximeter which is your
breathing was something like like 80 and
it should be 95 96 I couldn't get a
breath I could hardly walk across the
room so they do
they went in and they cleaned out my
sinuses they Roto-Rooter to my sinuses
and it it did help it's helped and that
combined that with the tennis I'm
finally able to to breathe again how do
you get that tested your sinuses like if
it's they they shove a camera up there
up there and they could tell if you're
oh you got all this [ __ ] you can see
them and they it changed your life when
you figured that out and corrected it
well yeah before that what happened was
I was I was sicker and sicker and I
stopped working because I didn't want to
take a uh anything you do you have to
have insurance for and they send the
doctor your house and all he had to do
was listen to my lungs put the
stethoscope to my back and it sounded
like like the rumble of the of you know
of like like or hurt an earthquake right
in other words I was uninsurable right
and I turned everything down because I
didn't want anybody to know it had its
own kind of insanity wow that went with
it and I was afraid to to let anybody
know and so you're risking your own life
because you didn't want to seem
yeah somebody would hire you insane
isn't it that's crazy yeah health is
wealth well that's what your mother
always said as long as you have your
health you're wealthy and there's 200
for there's a hundred percent truth to
that you know and and the the do you
have a caregiver with your mother
um she has someone
she has my stepdad and uh she's going to
a lot of doctors he has insurance so you
know we'll see what happens I mean she's
doing she's okay I don't know I I don't
know I just remember when she was she's
back in Indiana yeah
so um she's you know we're figuring it
out we're figuring it out but um it's
called practicing medicine yeah that's
one of the problems if you if you have
something that is routine that's easily
diagnosable you're okay
and they can do Miracles with hearts
with heart today of course not so much
cancer yeah that's that's yeah that's it
you can't figure that out and if you
don't have something that is that is
easily diagnosable you're in for what I
went through which is years of going
from one doctor to another and trying
this and trying that and everything else
I know how that goes yeah have you uh
ever dealt with any depression in your
life do you get were you one of those
guys that one of those people who are
attached to a project and when it it it
doesn't succeed like you thought you
kind of go into a hole yes and what
would you do in the beginning like what
did you learn from that was it something
that you
it kept happening and how did you
correct that or how did you how did you
learn to deal with it in a healthy way
I think
they're creating a successful piece of
art I.E a movie
there's a lot of luck involved people
don't like to hear that but it is making
a movie is such a group effort and it
requires the skill and talent of so many
people
that you have to be blessed
the actors have to have some kind of
connection some kind of charisma
the cinematographer has to arrive and
not fall asleep while they're setting up
a shot
the the set decorator can't be behind
the uh behind the flats doing something
you shouldn't he's got to be dressing
the set really well and you know it
really on and on everything doesn't come
yep you know the quality I mean if
something's missing it could
create something that you know something
will fail because of that I had
extraordinary luck on Fright Night
and since it was the first movie that I
directed I didn't know it was atypical
that was a great cast it's a great
cinematographer it was yeah I had John
de Cure senior doing the production
design I had I had I had Richard edlin I
had Steve Johnson I had Randy cook doing
the effects I mean I could just I I
inherited the ghost Ghostbusters Crow
wow I inherited for fright night this
little movie that nobody paid attention
to that everybody thought was a possible
way that they gave me because there was
one slot left in the distribution and
they didn't expect anything but I got
not probably because of the success of
the screenplays but because Guy mcelaine
knew me from Sunday salons at Pamela
Mason's house I never said that to me
but I suspect did you get nervous when
you were your first directorial debut
where you constantly under a lot of
stress and couldn't sleep and was
worried you're gonna get fired and all
these things was this happening or were
you confident and comfort terrible and
hunky dory that happened to me on
child's play it didn't happen to me on
fright night so what happened on Child's
Play you just were really stressed out
well I was really stressed out because
you try to make a damn doll work you
know with the way I wrote that script of
things
you know yeah well that was a huge laugh
the biggest laugh ever but I mean the
doll I mean I I
nobody had ever tried to make a puppet
movie of that of that of that
specificity and yeah complexity and
there were a ton of shots that didn't
work there were a ton of things worked
you know I'd written for the doll to do
this or that and they couldn't do it and
then I had to figure out well put them
behind Furniture swim and run them along
behind Furniture so we don't see the
Puppeteer or whatever it was you know
but it was unending and I I kept I was
terrified we were going to show the film
and the audience was going to laugh at
the doll I was afraid they wouldn't
believe Chucky could be murderous and be
really I I didn't I was afraid they
wouldn't believe Chucky could kill you
wow and those are huge fears because
that's the entire movie that's the
entire movie and I did not really know
until the first preview and the first
preview all of the Chucky set pieces
meaning nothing would Now call The Kills
but all of the all of the things I used
to build suspense you could see that it
was all working you could see the
audience have fallen in love with Chucky
and it was it was the first first one
out and after that the previews were a
matter of tightening frightening the
film did you cast Brad Dorff as the
voice of Chucky after you were completed
filming no I know I wrote it for him you
wrote it for him he had been the bad guy
in the movie that I'd done previously
that that nobody ever asked me about
called fatal Beauty with Whoopi Goldberg
but who's doing the voice during filming
I was so you're going [ __ ] you yeah and
all those things you were doing the
voice oh yeah yeah yeah I bet that was
kind of fun all it was it was a lot of
fun I mean the only thing that's kept me
at all at all saying is I've tried to
rehearse every movie that I've done I
think that's huge and it it it I had I
had a solid two weeks on fright night
and I was dealing with a really
professional cast Roddy McDowell Chris
Sarandon well Roddy McDowell and Chris
both supported me yeah and that carried
the other actors including Stephen
Jeffers Hey Stephen the uh yeah I mean
the you know the we I took and I ran
that entire movie as a play on a Sound
Stage taping out the the the the the
rooms you know how big they were and
everything else
and I had Colin Higgins come down to
watch it do you know Colin is Colin
wrote a few things like uh Silver Streak
yeah uh nine to five sure uh Best Little
Whorehouse in Texas yeah Colin was Colin
was was some kind of Genius he died
early so you wanted him to be on set he
came down and looked at it and told me
whether or not it worked he had also
read the screenplay and gave me a few
jokes he could do comedies as always is
what Colin he gave me the uh the mother
the lines of the mother had you want a
uh a tranquilizer it was a big laugh
whatever it was then Sonoma I forgot
what it was but you know I woke up from
a nightmare and there I was naked you
know in a white sale you know I that was
right anyway so Colin came down and
Colin was extremely supportive
and supportive of the cast from what
he's seen yeah and uh Colin was at that
moment telling one of the top directors
in Hollywood wow so he was a huge huge
help and God bless Colin this is called
[ __ ] talking with Tom Holland this is my
top tier patrons who get to ask
questions uh if you want to become a
patron and support the podcast you know
I love y'all message after go to
patreon.com inside of you
uh this is from Raj this is fast talk
this is a rapid fire
so you answer Rapid Fire fast okay Raj
tell me about a time you struggled to
get the right performance out of an
actor how did you work through it
I failed sometimes I can't I don't want
to name names
uh uh Stephen Jeffries well I just had
to point him and he went uh I had
terrible trouble on the temple film
another film that nobody asked me about
uh what about thinner
no thinner was thinner was a great
experience and a terrible experience I
had a wonderful actor there Robert John
Burke and then I and I did I did I did I
did rehearse that and I thought
everybody was just terrific
and
that was a very difficult piece it's a
character piece
I enjoyed it I enjoyed thinner it wasn't
too disturbing for you no I liked it it
was it was it was dark it was weird it
was I remember seeing it in the theater
um but when you have trouble with an
actor do you ever Raise Your Voice do
you ever get mad do you ever lose your
[ __ ] have you ever lost your [ __ ] Tom
Holland
yeah a number of times but I never lost
it I don't don't think I ever lost it
with actors have you ever said God damn
it I told you to do that move to yeah
well what happens is you're as as the
movie proceeds has got closer and closer
to the end the pressure from the studio
Builds on you to finish it to cut the uh
to save money I don't think I've ever
been involved in a movie where they
weren't knocking on the door in the last
two or three weeks saying can we cut
this can we cut that and it's just
horrible it's always stressful you got
that guy on set who's like we gotta go
we gotta go you're gonna miss it you
can't do that we got to cut this and
you're all you're always ending up at
Magic hour with three shots left that
you need and time for only one always
that's all that's always always 99 more
do you have any recurring nightmares if
so what do you think they stem from
growing up oh I can't answer trouble uh
no I mean I love I love my parents
dearly yes but I mean I'm I'm I'm a
little sensitive about how how revealing
personally I should be under to these
circumstances of room we're having a
private conversation here but six
million people or whatever may be
listening in I wish six million people
were listening but this is great this is
what people want to hear they want to
hear the real you this is like you know
anyway Danny awesome guest love Tom
Holland would love to hear Tom's
favorite story about working with the
legendary Roddy McDowell he's fantastic
in Fright Night as we all know so a
quick story that you could remember Rock
story I I I cast Roddy because of it
because of the performance in class of
84. if you look at that he's terrific
amazing and Roddy came in to meet with
me and Roddy said he's the he's the lion
isn't he I said the lion he said yes
from Wizard of Oz
he's
he's the lion without a heart he is he
has no courage and he finds his courage
and that's my image that's brilliant and
I thought that's brilliant you have the
part yes holy [ __ ] oh lovely colors
though but he kind of was Peter was like
that Vincent he has the hero's journey
he does he starts to become strong he
starts that weak and just like a facade
yes and that's unusual usually that
would be given to Charlie but Charlie's
the motor right that makes it go and if
you want all the answers to why this is
by Friday night Origins because I
explained the novel get it you guys are
gonna love it yeah little Lisa what's
the scariest thing you've ever done and
why'd you do it
the scariest thing I've ever done in
making a movie anything I put uh I put
the little person in uh Child's Play I
put a body harness on him and I had him
walk a ledge five or six floors above
above ground
for over the camera with him in the
Chucky and a full Chucky costume which
means he couldn't see that well when he
goes and he's getting the little boy
inside the insane asylum yeah I mean so
I've done so you were scared at that
moment like something's gonna happen
yeah but I needed the shot let's see
let's see but see that that that's the
craziness of directing when you when
you're in the directing and you're
really into it if you think you need a
shot you'll do anything for the shot yes
I mean it it i i it's just that there's
a there is a there is a ruthlessness
involved that one would never admit to
for fear of being unsympathetic
everything for the art what do you do
about your um we're wrapping this up but
what do you do when you're depressed
when we talked about that briefly but
like everything rides on this and it
fails in your eyes and you get depressed
what gets you out of depression time
a lot of time if you look at if you were
to look at my career you can find long
periods when I was down and that was
because I was turning everything down
what did you turn down what were the
biggest things you turned down RoboCop
the original mistake yeah
uh wow yeah that uh oh I can't I already
turned down a lot of stuff I turned out
a whole lot of stuff did you ever turn
down something because you were
you it was fear based like I can't do
this I couldn't do that yeah if if if if
the if the technical knowledge that was
required ran
beyond my expertise
I was very nervous because I would have
to depend on somebody else the effects
supervisor telling me whether or not it
was possible and the more you get into
film the less you trust people as far as
that's concerned right what do you um I
love actress by the way yeah I know that
you could tell you love actors and they
love you I've talked to Chris Sarandon
who just admires you so much and uh
So many actors that just love you adore
you
um our good friend Nick Peterson I love
Nick loves you he loves you
um
do you ever tell your age I mean you can
look online see how old you are yeah of
course well I I became no well-known so
really I didn't lie about my age I
turned 79 last July 79 we're born on the
same day July 11th are you really you
and I have the same birthday no kidding
yes we do there's got to be something
and there's a connection that's amazing
we're both sensitive
but at 79 most people when they're 70
60s they'd be like I'm good I made a
fortune I have a big house I created
these huge franchises I've got money I
don't need to worry I'm not doing
anything else I'm retiring at 79 you
just wrote a novel
Fright Night Origins that's out where
you guys need to get do you think that
you've got another movie in you do you
think you want to direct again or write
another screenplay or do you feel the
need that you have to
and if you do are you doing it for you
or are you doing it to prove yourself
because you don't need to prove yourself
but what is it what gets you going right
now I am really pissed at the accounting
in Hollywood I really hate the majors
they all cheat you blind I have I have
been I have spent a lot of money with
lawyers in the last two or three years
with forensic accounting on fright night
and Child's Play and I'm now on the
Queue to be I have to there are so many
people suing the Hollywood Studios for
their accounting then you have to wait
two three four years in line
before they'll before they'll take the
case in court Jesus I mean the I look at
Child's Play and I I really forget the
numbers now but what they do is they
they charge you such a high interest
rate like 17
on whatever the unpaid amount of the
debt is so that they set it up so that
the interest rate on the deficit is
always growing larger and is larger than
the profits coming in is worked out
right so as time goes along the film
Fright Night Child's Play psycho 2 Falls
deeper into debt
now I figure I have made billions for
Hollywood
none of which not even the taste of
which they passed on I'll tell you a
very brief story about Tony Perkins
talking to Tony after uh Child's Play
after uh psycho too psycho two had
become a huge International hit it was
going for something like a hundred
million dollars worldwide and Tony
called and said uh I have a worse worse
I have I have I have points where's
where's my profit statements and they
told them they didn't have any profits
we had done that movie for 4.9 for a
little bit less than five maybe 34
million first weekend yeah and would be
done it for a little less than five
million that was the actual real cost
and Universal was saying they were still
in debt and so Tony said I'm going to
sue you and Universal and I will not say
the executive who said this said you do
that and you will never work in
Hollywood again to Tony Perkins he's
saying this and so Tony said he says
back yeah sure until the next time you
need me okay Tony directed psycho three
and he directed it because he was so
pissed off at Universal trying to short
him on his proper participation and also
when he did that and they had to pay
Tony his Prophet to participation I got
43 000 in deferred salary
and that's Hollywood for you
if you can't sue you're never going to
see anything on the back end that's true
pisses me off I wanted to see someone
once well but no but if you if you'd
ever had a piece of of any of those
beyond the residuals you could ever have
it a piece of Superman
you'd be in this too this this has been
incredible I love talking to you yes you
can come back of course uh this I
there's so much else to talk about so
many stories okay a real a real quick
one all right my father was a diagnosed
manic depressive on lithium maintenance
for the last 13 years of his life and he
was institutionalized once
end of it okay thank you very much hang
on hang on
um wow you were an extraordinary man
you're a super talented guy uh I love
you I'm gonna come over and play tennis
with you I'm going to visit the wifey I
miss her and uh this has been a real
treat guys buy the book Fright Night
Origins this is this is a legend that's
here with us today and thank you all
very much for listening and I can't tell
you how terrific Michael Rosenbaum is
both as an actor and even more
importantly as a human being you hear
that guys
coming from a legend thanks Tom thanks
for allowing me to be inside of you
today thank you
I love it I love it I love hearing about
like how he's not getting money for like
all the sequels of Child's Play it sucks
like I don't like it I think it's just
horrid and you can tell that he's
obviously a little upset it's like you
put your heart and soul into something
and then your contract says oh you don't
get anything and then I guess that's his
lawyer's fault oh you wouldn't be if you
were listening you wouldn't be able to
know but he was wearing Chucky socks
Chucky he's wearing Chucky socks and uh
I asked him like if he was getting
residuals on the merch and it doesn't
sound like it no uh I love you Tom
thanks for being here go check out his
uh new book watch fright night if you've
never seen it Child's Play I don't know
how you've not seen that one
um
but uh thank you guys for supporting the
podcast right now to talk to your
patrons the shout outs
um become a patron today join us and
support us I can do it without you
patreon.com inside you hear the names
top tiers Nancy D Leah s Sarah V little
Lisa you Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P
Robert B Jason W Sophie and Kristen K
Raj C Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L
Jamal F Janelle B Kimberly e Mike E
changing glasses so we can read yes
please hold the glasses
oh there we go well done Supremo 99 more
Santiago am Chad W Liam P Janine R Maya
P Maddie s Belinda and Chris H Dave and
Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T Tom and
Liliana a latalya and Betsy D Chad L
Marion Dan n big Stevie W Angel M
Rhiannon see Cory K Dev next and
Michelle a Jeremy C Andy T gavinator
David C John B Brandy D Camille ask Joey
M Eugene and
Leah Nikki G Corey Katie B Patricia
Heather L Megan T Mount s Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Sarah s Eric H sh
Shane r l r Jeremy V Andrew M zedoichi
77 Oracle Chris R Karina and Michelle D
Amanda R Jen B Kevin e Stephanie K Lina
82 jorel and Billy
s
couldn't do it with that you guys uh
it's been a real treat being here with
you every week weekend week out uh
cumulus picked up the show for another
year so go for another year at least and
uh you know that might be it but just
depends we need more listeners we need
more uh you know patrons we need here we
go thanks for allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you uh from the
Hollywood Hills in California I'm
Michael Rosenbaum I'm Ryan Taylor thank
you for listening watching thank you so
much and of course be good to yourselves
will you just be good to yourselves all
right we'll see
[Music]